for more on the future of antibiotics
and other major health issues i'm happy
to have the founding president of the
world health summit here with me in
studio detlef ganton thank you so much
for joining us here at tomorrow today
pleasure thank you now dr canton uh
we're still using antibiotics that were
developed almost in the middle of last
century and really none has come onto
the market in the last 20 years why is
that why aren't the pharma industry
investing in new antibiotics well so far
the antibiotics have been very effective
they've been widespreadly used
and now we have more and more resistance
to antibiotics bacteria grow despite the
treatment with antibiotics so we need
you
antibiotics which treat these specific
resistant germs
bacteria
but that's very expensive and and the
number of indications should be
restricted to just those who are
resistant and that's a small market so
far
so we need some models how this can be
can be done so that pharmaceutical
industry is interested in developing
them
and and they're on the money back for
the development
the european union and other
organizations are working on this model
and we have a major symposium actually
at the world trade summit to discuss
these issues which are very important
absolutely now um moving back to the
report for one moment and uh the idea of
using toxins and that have evolved in
insects to actually better
uh the antibiotics what do you think of
that idea
it's an excellent idea
i mean there is
no system more creative than nature so
you look at nature and how what you can
learn for treatment of other diseases
and this has been done in the past and
and this is i think a wonderful idea to
to pursue i'm sure it will be successful
absolutely now the world held so much
what are the pressing issues this year
worldwide summit health is much more
than medicine so so we
try to get together politicians and and
civil society and and health economy and
of course also academia academia is
organizing that the m8 alliance
and we have to the world summit is a
forum to discuss topics like
antibiotics like infrastructure research
infrastructure in other countries what
is going on in certain
areas of the world how can we help and
how can we improve health
in specific ways but also in more
general terms of course in the long term
you're saying that basically it's a
forum for lots of different leaders and
lots of different people from academia
politics uh the healthcare um the pharma
industry for example there's there's so
many different agendas there how do you
all agree on on a solution
we won't agree on everything but we take
out a few areas where we do have
agreement which are particularly urgent
antibiotics will have a statement of the
national academies and which will then
be
given to national governments and to
organizations the european union for
example is interested in developing this
topic and so we give some advice there
we look at regions like the
mediterranean area where as we all know
there is a lot of turmoil and
instability and people are suffering
medical care is not assured anymore so
we do have recommendations on this topic
we make recommendations on research
infrastructure in certain areas which is
very important for the future ted
lefkanton thank you so much for joining
us here at tomorrow today thank you very
much